welcome back everyone is Charlie we have
a brand new Rick and Morty season four
official trailer to breakdown and we're
getting it a week earlier than I thought
it was going to drop there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs they're dropping
bodies like flies in this to r.i.p
gearhead r.i.p Morty's 10 free
adventures I will be doing episode
videos and Easter eggs all season long
so be sure to subscribe if you're brand
new to my channel there's also a merch
giveaway that I'm doing every week that
I'll explain at the end of the video
important stuff first though they're
officially premiering the season
November 10th and those are gonna air
five episodes go on break for the
holidays then come back and air the
second half of the season there's ten
episodes total in season four so it's
just the first half of the season that
we're getting right now they did the
exact same thing during season one so
I'll talk about that second block of
episodes at the end of the video but all
this footage in the trailer is from
across those five new episodes not just
the first two or three episodes the
first clip is also from that preview
that they released earlier this year of
Rick looking all blissful walking
through the tall grass they seemingly
fly to this tropical lush planet is hard
to tell based on way they cut the
trailer but this next clip of them
entering the ancient temple looking like
an Indiana Jones parody mix with some
guardians of the galaxy seems like it's
all happening on the same planet they
have all these traps in the ceiling the
floor with the robot statues the statues
even kind of looked like the Droid
ACCA's from Star Wars Episode one
Phantom Menace
Rick and Morty put on those clear
looking bulletproof armor jackets and it
looks like Rick's going full-on world
Endor episode levels of not caring about
the danger like he could care less about
what's happening here with all these
traps even Morty doesn't seem that
concern but maybe at this point they've
had so many adventures together that he
started to trust Rick's technology a
little more even if he still doesn't
completely trust Rick himself whatever
his secret reasons might be it sounds
like Morty wanted to use the last of his
10 free adventure card punches like
we're gonna have to call this one an
adventure boom as he clears out his
adventure card I guess we're gonna to
start a new one of these so apparently
that's why Rick brings him to this
planet the scene of Rick eating fast
food on his hover chair while Morty is
free climbing the cliff face without any
ropes it's just a parody of Star Trek 5
the final frontier if you haven't seen
that movie it's not one of the better
Star Trek's general rule of thumb for
the original series movies is that the
even number ones are the good ones but
it's literally that exact same scene you
have Kirk climbing the
faced without any special technology
like more tea than Spock using the hover
boots to talk to him just making fun of
the whole thing like Rick is doing
asking the question what's the point of
climbing this mountain he even falls off
the cliff face just like Captain Kirk
did Spock had to use the hover boost to
rescue him from being dashed on the
rocks below so apparently Rick is
probably gonna have to do the same thing
here but you also noticed that Rick is
eating Arby's because they flashed the
rapper pretty prominently I'm assuming
that this is just official product
placement to earn the show some extra
money they've actually done stuff like
this before they even did a full-blown
Carl's jr. commercial why you got to
keep selling us out Rick they just earns
them a whole bunch of extra money from
those advertisers that pay to have their
products put in the episodes they shot
of them running with the cat person
named chachi is on a different planet
but the color of the terrain makes it
seem a little bit like the mega seeds
planet that's probably just a
coincidence though because you don't see
any of those trees in the background
they just seem like they're there to
steal something from this other group of
aliens that are chasing them down r.i.p
chachi you will be remembered until
another quirky character is introduced
to the group then on a different planet
good to see you Rick still cares about
Morty sheltering from the laser blast
but there are different colors so it
seems like it's a completely different
group that they're running from with
this giant geode that they're running to
hide behind then apparently Rick gives
Morty a dragon to take care of in one of
the episodes whither he makes one or
they just bring one from another planet
this is probably just the show taking
shots at Game of Thrones Season eight
because then Rick refers to summer as
quote-unquote Queen as in Queen Daenerys
Targaryen mother of dragons pretty safe
bet that they're gonna have some Game of
Thrones themed Rick Dragonslayer merch
also glad to see that the meeseeks are
back finally people been asking for a
couple seasons now when they're gonna
come back in a big way
but they're tearing [ __ ] up on the
regular just riding in the streets the
funny thing about this too is that they
look super happy while they're doing it
unlike the me6 episode from season 1
when they were losing their minds
because they couldn't die so this might
be some accident that someone gets into
where they asked the meeseeks to do
something it in pursuit of that task
they wind up just completely going crazy
because then you see Morty wearing a
very Nazi inspired looking uniform on
Rick's spaceship fighting a meeseeks
with gearhead in the back crapping his
pants and morty straight up winds up
shooting him in the head r.i.p gearhead
for some reason summer and Beth are
going at it dueling with golf clubs and
assorted bagage items from the airport
tarmac here while this baggage handler
in the background could just give a crap
just going about his job like it's no
big deal
there's a giant hole in the glass
walkway up here too so they are really
tearing into each other for some reason
but then Morty looks like he's on some
adventure by himself because they have
that big Acura reference literally the
cop in the cop car calls it out over the
comm we got an Akira type situation
going on behind the mall here everybody
knows the basic premise of Akira the
government experimenting on kids trying
to create super soldiers until they
start to evolve beyond their control the
main antagonist Tetsuo starts going
crazy growing at an exponential rate
akira the titular character has to
reform his body to stop him then they
get sucked into a black hole and it's
implied the Tetsuo becomes so powerful
that he creates an entire new universe
if you don't remember earlier this year
they even released a Rick and Morty
style trailer for Akira
[Music]
[Applause]
this screaming head in the microwave
inside the garage is giving me
flashbacks to the ABCs of Beth from
season 3 where Beth and Jerry had to
clone Tommy and then stick him in the
microwave as part of the process
here's another akira joke when Rick
gives Morty that special burn ointment
and says you're gonna die if you don't
leave this on long enough but if you
leave it on too long I'll have to hunt
what you become just like they have to
hunt down
Tetsuo during the akira movie which
morty then completely fails at because
he begins to turn into this winged demon
looking monstrosity charging away with
rick going after him with his gun morty
and jerry going on in an adventure what
could possibly go wrong this actually
looks like it's part of that glooty
episode that they released a comic-con
with tyga YTD playing the app developer
alien that was sassing them there was a
spaceship in orbit that they kept
referring to during that clip so this
might be that the aliens feet sticking
out of their armor also looks exactly
like Lu Dee's feet this is Rick and
Morty looking like they're crashing some
kind of alien meeting or convention this
might be a joke about Hall H at Comic
Con or just some general comic-con joke
because of the Marvel Doctor Strange
joke and in this exterior shot of the
alien city you see all these heist
convention banners with Rick stealing
these alien spaceship while they're busy
trying to heist all this material off
the building a heist within a heist but
Rick does show off some new personal
safety tech that causes him to phase the
security guard the Doctor Strange joke
is just them literally ripping off dr.
strange the writers making fun of
themselves for ripping off the plot of
that movie with the sentient cloak of
levitation choking an enemy out Rick
Morty and some are escaping during a
different adventure that looks like some
sort of sci-fi fantasy mashup Dungeons &
Dragons style some are wearing an outfit
that looks like it's inspired by Lord of
the Rings or The Hobbit this seems odd
but Rick's weapon is turning aliens into
footballs and other random objects like
he shoots this alien then punched the
football that he turns into he's known
for having weird guns that turn people
into other things like the gun that
turned people into snakes but that was
pure science and he keeps referring to
magic in this episode I could get used
to this magic hard to tell if this is
random because the guns then shoots the
next alien and turns it into a potted
plan also news rick has morphine built
into a spinal cord I'm sure that's gonna
come in handy welcome back mr. poopy
butthole who's a pair
living as a professor with hostel
students who for some reason are trying
to attack him but he's apparently now a
ninja who's fighting them off with his
cane looks like he's actually pretty
badass too already complaining about
dying Rick shrugging it off that's
pretty much their relationship his
wounds here actually look a lot like the
wounds during mortise mine blowers when
he was trying to get rid of that giant
demon tapeworm inside of him and for
some reason there's a dead astronaut
snake on their dashboard inside an
astronaut suit with a cracked helmet and
what looks like an American flag snakes
in space who knows what's going on here
and then they remind you five episodes
November 10th that means if they don't
take a break for Thanksgiving then
Episode five will air December 8th the
go on break for the holidays then
hopefully they'll come back in January
to air the second block of five episodes
like I said they did the exact same
thing during season one and when they
came back in January it was the second
week in January so you have to wait that
long through the holiday is to get
brand-new episodes but it's hard to tell
if they're gonna do this from now on
where they air smaller blocks of
episodes multiple times a year or if
this is just because of the holidays
we're doing a merch giveaway every week
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just leave your favorite
Rick and Morty moment from the trailer
on the video I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post my next video I had one
ready to go I wasn't expecting this
trailer to drop so that new Rick and
Morty video should post in the next week
while you wait for everything click here
for all my Rick and Morty's season 4
promos and trailer videos and click here
for my joker movie review thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]